let's talk about nato
it's the military and political alliance
set up by the west after world war ii in
response to the soviet union's growing
power we will now proceed to the signing
of the north atlantic treaty
more than 70 years later with russia's
invasion of ukraine people are now
talking about a new cold war
and nato's purpose seems to have come
full circle we face the most serious
security crisis in a generation and
therefore nato needs to respond right
now nato's focus is on its eastern front
it's sending more soldiers and equipment
to countries like lithuania where we are
we're here to see exactly what nato is
doing
it's a bit of a bumpy ride but they're
taking us to a place where some
reinforcements have just arrived
we'll find out why lithuanians feel
vulnerable when it comes to russia
and why nato's strategy now seems to be
catching up with how people here see
things
right let's go through some nato basics
to start us off nato stands for north
atlantic treaty organization and at its
core is this idea of collective defense
basically an attack against one member
is seen as an attack against all of them
if you've heard of article 5 that's
essentially what it says
now nato started off in 1949 with just
12 members today it's got 30 and the us
has always been the biggest military
power but there's also the uk most of
europe and turkey lithuania joined in
2004 along with six other countries
either all of them had been part of the
soviet union at one point or within its
sphere of influence the door to nato
will remain open
until the whole of europe
is united in freedom
and in peace
[Applause]
i think there was a lot of euphoria
after
2004 at least here
in the baltic states it seemed like the
end of the cold war
brought a lasting peace to european
continent of course the relationship
with russia was becoming increasingly
complicated back then vladimir putin had
only been president for a few years but
his worldview and ambitions to restore
russia as a global power were becoming
clearer this speech was a pretty big
clue
so putin was watching all these
countries that had all been part of the
soviet space signing up to nato and he
saw it as a major threat he accused nato
of breaking a promise to never expand
eastward but nato says there was no
promise it goes back to 1990 and a
conversation between the u.s secretary
of state and the leader of the soviet
union over the status of a unified
germany historians are still debating
what was or wasn't said and what it all
meant
there have been other critics of nato's
eastern expansion too and not only on
the russian side george kennan was a top
u.s diplomat who shaped u.s policy
against the soviet union during the cold
war in 1998 he told the new york times i
think the russians will gradually react
quite adversely and it will affect their
policies i think it is a tragic mistake
there was no reason for this whatsoever
no one was threatening anybody else now
nato didn't have much of a military
presence in the east until after 2014.
what america is officially calling a
russian invasion of ukraine russian
troops spreading out throughout the
strategic crimean peninsula after
russia's invasion and annexation of
crimea nato decided to send combat
forces to the east for the first time
it set up four battle groups each with
around a thousand soldiers in estonia
latvia lithuania and poland but now
after russia's most recent invasion of
ukraine nato's beefing up those existing
battle groups
and adding four new ones
nato is refocusing back to territorial
defense back to increasing military
capacities personnel
in in those
eastern flank
nato states
so this is essentially set up for us the
media but it's to show us the kind of
hardware that's just arrived
there are radar systems and stinger air
defense missiles the kind being used by
the ukrainian army it's basically stuff
that helps shoot other stuff out of the
sky that's how one officer put it
more soldiers have arrived too we are
now up to 1 600 1700 soldiers that means
we are reinforced by nearly 500 soldiers
right now
they're part of the 40 000 troops that
nato says are now under its direct
command stationed along its eastern
flank
but the baltic states are saying even
those kinds of numbers aren't enough
anymore
we're going to get back to nato strategy
in a bit but first let's understand why
lithuania feels vulnerable to begin with
there's the geography on one side
lithuania's got kaliningrad a russian
territory that is highly militarized
and on the other is a long border with
russia's close ally belarus which has
been a base for russian forces attacking
ukraine
and then there's the history lithuania
regained its independence in the early
90s when the soviet union collapsed
before that it had been a part of the
ussr for nearly 50 years
there aren't really many signs of that
era left but we're going to a place
where much of it's been preserved in a
theme park
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
regime was brutal
massive depressions massive deportations
about 300 000 people were sent to gulat
to siberia do you remember seeing these
statues yes i do yes they do they were a
part of my childhood
my grandmother lived in vilnius and
lennon was very close to her in the red
square but i do remember the moment when
he was removed i was standing there with
my father and my dad said that's a huge
moment you know that's a huge moment
because the collapse of the soviet union
um in the 1991 that was such a
major geopolitical event which started a
new era
that new era put lithuania on a new path
one that was very different to russia's
under president putin
the
accession into the eu and nato
was very much seen as a return to
so-called the west broadly speaking
countries united by the same
principles of democratic governance and
market economies
[Music]
now if you look at recent polls
lithuanians overwhelmingly support being
part of the european union and being a
member of nato those are some pretty
strong signs of just how far the
country's moved on from its fairly
recent soviet past
[Music]
you just have to look around vilnius to
see how strongly the war in ukraine
resonates with lithuanians
there are flags everywhere on balconies
in restaurants even the buses have
messages of support
and some of that comes from a sense of
shared history and values our values are
very similar i believe that the
ukrainian people wanted freedom
they wanted fair elections they wanted
democratic institutions they wanted
transparent institutions and
because we share these values and we
know
how difficult it is sometimes to get
those values we we feel like brothers
and sisters it's like written under our
skin
what we are talking about because we are
really near to russia
we can feel it so there's quite a strong
feeling here that they understand the
issues around russia and security better
than most and leaders in this region
have been talking about what they see as
a russian threat for a long time now
well before the war in ukraine
politics
is
and nato is now rethinking its strategy
in a big way right now its battle groups
in the east serve as what's called a
tripwire defense basically enough
soldiers to slow down an invading army
but nowhere near enough to defeat it
so they're talking about a new plan
nato's secretary general is calling it a
reset moving away from tripwire
deterrence to something more about
denial or defense what he means is a
much bigger force one that would be
capable of taking on an invading army
and on top of that sweden and finland
are now thinking seriously about joining
nato too
they've both been neutral for decades
and finland joining would double the
length of nato's border with russia
it's another example of how the war in
ukraine has shifted things and not in a
way that president putin wants
we're just outside the russian embassy
in vilnius and just look at the messages
people are sending the kremlin this
reads putin the hague is waiting that
says glory to ukraine they've even
renamed this street ukrainian hero
street now whatever plan putin had in
ukraine
this overwhelming pro-ukrainian
anti-russian sentiment probably wasn't
part of it and the same goes for nato
putin has given this western military
alliance new purpose
and an even stronger foothold in what he
considers to be his backyard
[Music]
you